what do you feel uh like right now
because like since the pandemic came and
went uh a bunch of clubs closed then i
feel like the nightlife scene is kind of
true interesting in l.a right now how do
you feel about it i mean
i you know what deeb is my brother i
talked to d the other day and i was i
was so frustrated with him he like what
and that's my brother and when i say
this i'm passionate enough to say it
because like i love these guys like
he probably one of the only people i
come in the club he like bro don't spend
no money tonight i got you you know what
i'm saying so we need people like that
but i was frustrated with him the other
day and i texted him he like l.a
function you coming and i'm like i don't
see myself on no flyer
he like brother i've been waiting on you
to come i i try to set up with your
manager i'm like bro you have la
function without the la
guys
right
like how do you have an la function
without la
i think uh
was this the one that was just a bunch
of djs i don't know what it was but
because they know they did an la
function and it was like i am l.a tons
of djs i didn't see any artists on it
maybe i'm tripping right i am when i say
this
i'm respected because i speak truth and
i speak reality i don't come on no
microphone and bootleg cave show to
speak down on anybody else i just speak
the truth
i am la it's only facts it's only a
couple of people that really represent
la like
bro it's no way in hell why are you
doing an la function that i'm not on the
la function or the guys that do
represent la the right way it's on the
la function there's no way in hell could
that be because maybe they don't know
cause look at the end of the day like i
said you've been building up so much
other [ __ ] no that's good freak it's
been out for two months month and a half
no i came to the la function to spend
some dough
i just mean in terms of like
maybe you're not put like like it would
make sense if you put out some music
yeah at the same time well if you had
music out like
i did i just i i've been like just uh
nobody put music out that was that they
was booking i thought it was all dj's no
they have
they have blue bucks they have blue
bucks the first day i'm thinking of that
of the day he's thinking about huh there
was like the big la function festival
and it was just all djs they had blue
bucks the first day
blue bucks is from la they had blue
bucks the first day i'm talking about
they had a beta la too so they had
kamiyah you know i'm saying but i'm
talking i don't think they're on the
flyer even with no music out who don't
want to come see
two hours of joe i can perform for two
hours
i got hits like
i just think that like at least the
flyers i've seen have been all djs i
don't think they were booking talent
maybe i'm telling you for sure
yeah i think fools were just pulling up
that's that's what makes it bad they're
just boring why you didn't
that's what i'm saying he got he got he
don't have to drop tomorrow he got
consistent records to still turn up the
la function i think they booked i just
think they booked djs no i'm telling you
they not you you wanna
that's what i mean
was brian sampson been blowing you up
no he blowing you up
yo i'm in the middle of an interview bud
what the [ __ ] can i do for you
where you at are you outside do you need
someone to let you in brian sampson
[ __ ] off then
jesus christ
this is the guy you got to hang around
with working your record happy [ __ ]
fast shout out to brian
working my record like a month how's the
bride he is working your record